zach overall 10-8 2.77 earned run
average
he is still one of if not the leading
candidate for the national league cy
young award but it has taken a little
bit of a hit the last couple games
uh joey was uh meeting with some of the
avon grove legion team
that was here tonight getting a chance
to catch up with him that was kind of a
cool moment for some of those youngsters
the older guys the younger guys
he bounces that to third big hop for the
reyes
three ground balls three outs
for zach willard
and one two three go the raise
middle of the first left-hander ryan
yarbrough making his 18th start of the
season looking for win number eight era
4.57 coming off a very efficient and
effective outing against the baltimore
orioles
[Applause]
shot right to wendell down at third on a
line and rio murdo
is out number two
and a line drive out to right center
field that'll be in for a hit
and harper will hold up at first
so a two out single
[Applause]
breaks his bat in the ground ball left
side
a flip to lao to take care of harper
matt is gone first inning is over no
score
they got nelson cruz of course but you
know look at a lot of these guys on that
team saying it's huge power guys
swinging to miss by rosarina
they went out
that looked like it hurt yeah
pop-up outside of third to reyes
he picks him up
side is retired no runs
he whacks that one out to left center
field that's going to drop in for a hit
rosarita makes the play and mccutcheon
is aboard
[Applause]
it's back toward the middle and it leaks
into center field to base it mccutchen
will hold up
he didn't take the
perfect route
to third because i don't know if he
thought it was going to be
turned into a double play so luke
williams the number eight hitter get a
chance to bat here with the bases loaded
and sharply to third wendell goes to
second for one over to first low throw
and it's in time a run scores
and the phillies are on top one nothing
wheeler
shoots it into left that ball will be
caught a grab and a dive for
rosarina to retire the side rays get out
of a bases loaded
nobody out situation they give up only
one
and trail won nothing through two nicely
done in line
[Applause]
swinging a mess
and mejia strikes out that's number two
for zach wheeler
bouncer to first reece has got it fair
ball
and the inning is over 3-1 on the put
out
one two three
go the raise it's an 11-pitch inning
this pitch is
hit deep to left but not
deep enough for the phillies just in
front of the track a rosarina
takes care of that
headed toward the corner
harper's gonna have to play the carom
and franco's on his way to second with
the double to extend his hitting streak
and his on base streak
another raise with an opportunity
putting the lead off man on
lifted toward left center it's going to
hang up and it's misplayed mccutcheon
just missed that ball picked up by
williams
wendell winds up at second how about
that and the rays get on the board
last two pitchers to strike out 200 in a
season before their 26th
lefty and kurt chilling as phillips goes
down swinging
he's two away from his first uh 200
strikeout season
[Applause]
he has a ground ball through the right
side
a base hit to score wendell and the rays
take a 2-1 lead
on the first pitch diaz gets it through
the right side past hoskins that groin
is not 100 he may have hurt himself
[Applause]
[Music]
charging that one and a little slide
with that glove hand up he makes the
catch well here it is a nice shot there
my mccutcheon look at brett phillips
going down with the slide
head directly behind the glove see it
all the way in
one two pitch
swing at a missing a breaking ball
number 199 on the season for wheeler so
two out space is empty and there's
brandon lowell first pitch to him is
drilled to right field indeed harper
going back turns around and it's gone
brandon lau with a laser out to right
center his 30th home run of the season
and the rays have a 3-1 lead here in the
fifth
bryce singled his first time up walked
his last time
fly ball center field
kier myers just gonna watch that's gonna
be a long way gone
bryce harper has just tied this ball
game up at three
i mean he
absolutely crushed it
stolen 11 bags he's been caught seven
times there he goes swinging a miss
throw to second base on one hockey is
out at second base
beautiful hands from freddie galvez it
is strikeout number 200 for zach wheeler
he's done it 174 to third innings
he is the third quickest to 200
strikeouts of the season
seven k's a swing and a miss and a pitch
that was just sailing outside
and a strike three call 99 paints on the
outer half
will with eight strikeouts
he got him
number nine for zach wheeler the change
up
first and third rose arena will be the
hitter there's arena there's the ground
ball to short but they're going to have
to go to first
and the rays will get the run and take
the lead
[Applause]
swinging to miss
[Music]
tenth strikeout for zach wheeler
so now rhys hoskins they are going with
four outfitters
and reece smokes one to deep left field
it is gone
he just tied this game up
he went down and he got it
he's not 100
but man oh man does he make a difference
in this lineup now
two-minute in scoring position with
nobody out
there's a drive down the right field
line is that ball fair yes and it's gone
home run a little no two pitch francisco
the here
and that puts the rays out in front a
three-round blast it's 7-4 home run
number six for francisco mojilla
brad miller will hit for brogdon
one two
popped into short center gonna be caught
by kermeyer and the rays win it tonight
in philly
it's a 7-4 final and the rays who
are on a
pace 400 wins win tonight
you